ja hallo luther king
du bist du denn ich bin am 1
damit vorbei kommen ich muss mal mit ihm
reden jetzt nicht ich bin beim arzt
morgen um 4
aber danach danach ging museen in
ordnung
ich dachte
ciao können wir reden nicht hier und
nicht jetzt doch jetzt bitte
es gibt nicht zu reden ich wusste mir
das so locker befreundet sein
erst als mir gesagt dass du wohnst ist
mir das klar geworden das macht es auch
nicht besser
wie meinst du das dann hättest du mir
gesagt dass du eine freundin hast oder
hättest du das so ewig weiterlaufen
ich wollte es dir sagen natürlich
ich konnte auch nicht wissen dass ich
mich im weißt du was mir wirklich
wichtig ist
ehrlichkeit und ich kann keine beziehung
auf einer lüge aufbauen
lasst mich bitte allein
kann ich jetzt gehe moment war
was soll der quatsch du willst mich
verarschen oder meinst du das als ich
hier nach der tagschicht der
portemonnaie gegeben habe waren 150 euro
drin
199 ich glaube ich hatte den gästen zu
ihrem kölsch ein paar euro serviert hast
ich verstehe das nicht ich hab doch du
bist die einzige hut genommen haben
könnte tut mir leid otto du bist
gefeuert